[Music]
you're watching good day las vegas with
john langler
heather mills
sheri swensk and nate tannenbaum
good day las vegas live local now
6 44 on a friday morning it's time to
see what's trending with las vegas now
superstar
mercedes martinez there she is joining
us live from the mix 94.1 studios hey
mercedes happy friday
oh happy friday you guys are the
superstars and hope everyone is having a
great morning here is what's trending
first up taylor swift the singer she
just re-released her album red and it is
already breaking streaming records now
when it comes to the vinyl edition
though there's some complaints it has
her fans seeing red specifically the
limited edition red colored four discs
set from target it's getting poor
reviews because it was actually pressed
at 45 rpm instead of the standard 35 now
instead of people just changing the
setting on their record player fans are
freaking out they're saying why does her
voice sound so different why does she
sound like a man it doesn't even sound
like her so just turn that little
setting and it'll be all better next up
billy eilish she is pulling double duty
she's actually going to be hosting snl
on december 11th and
she's also gonna be that night's musical
guest now she has been on saturday night
live before but only as the musical
guest that was a couple of years ago the
first person to ever do both gigs
hosting and singing was actually paul
simon back in 1975. john heather wow
multi-talented yeah look forward to
seeing them okay we've been talking
about the holidays all morning they're
right around the corner mercedes and we
all know i'm obsessed i love it but in
this case i think maybe it's too far
yeah back in during halloween hidden
valley was encouraging us to give out
dressing packets at halloween seriously
poor kids what are they doing now
mercedes
oh that is nothing compared to what
they're doing now they're actually
selling a limited edition get this
holiday ranch nog kit
it includes everything you need to make
ranch flavored eggnog now hidden valley
they describe it as marrying the creamy
slightly sweet elements of eggnog with
the savory cool and herby flavors of
ranch it comes with two ranch nail
glasses and the seasoning packets to mix
into the recipe and you can get it for
50 bucks on their website john heather
50 bucks frequently mercedes people ask
me john what do you think of scary
movies i'm like yeah scary movies
whatever
that scares me ranch nog
that gives me weird faces and
i can't can't handle it my stomach's
already turning there is ranch and there
is gnaw and they're both excellent are
you are you pro nog mercedes
i am anti-nog i'm not a nogger i am more
of an apple cider
we're doggers yeah we're
we're both cyrus as well
i'm not inaugurated well i guess you can
be both right okay well then i'll drink
all of it all of yours heather's got the
nog mercedes you and i will share the
cider have a good weekend and no ranch
dog for any of us
have a good weekend mercedes
bye guys take care